pourvu que ça dure vous est présenté par
écho DDS éco-organismes qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les corresponds
savent sur Public Sénat aujourd'hui on
se demande comment faire pour mieux
associer les salariés à la performance
de leur entreprise les syndicales
patronats en discutent depuis trois mois
la demande du gouvernement qui veut que
le partage de la valeur soit un des
grands chantiers de cette année 2023
face à un pouvoir d'achat rogné par
l'inflation l'exécutif mise notamment
sur le dividende salarié on en parlera
avec celui qui l'a théorisé Thibault
langsad ancien numéro 2 du Medef depuis
les patrons jouent-ils suffisamment le
jeu de la redistribution des profits on
posera la question à Laurent Berger le
secrétaire général de la CVT qui sera
notre invité mais d'abord tout ce qu'il
faut savoir sur ces dispositifs de
partage de la valeur en moins d'une
minute c'est parti quels sont les outils
de partage de la valeur qui existe déjà
il y a d'abord la participation
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés il s'agit d'une prime
basée sur le bénéfice dégagé et versé à
tous les collaborateurs
en 2021 39% des salariés en ont
bénéficié pour un montant moyen de 1500
euros ensuite l'intéressement c'est une
prime annuelle facultative elle est
conditionnée à la performance de
l'entreprise en 2021 34% l'ont reçu pour
un montant moyen de 1909 euros ou encore
la prime de partage de la valeur qui
permet de verser jusqu'à 6000 euros de
bonus par an entre outre et septembre
2022 710 euros ont été versés à 2,5
millions de salariés combien de salariés
sont concernés dans le privé un peu plus
d'un salarié sur deux axé à un
dispositif de partage de la valeur dans
le détail ils sont 88% dans les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés et
moins de 20% dans celle de moins de 50
salariés et le gouvernement il veut
aller plus loin oui il a prévu
l'instauration d'un dividende salarié
l'objectif permettre un meilleur partage
des bénéfices en faveur des salariés
[Musique]
faut-il instaurer un dividende pour les
employeurs un titre que pour les
actionnaires oui il va nous dire
Thibault donc ça de bonjour bonjour
président de Luminess et président de
l'URSSAF c'est comme ça qu'on vous
appelle le théoricien donc du ce
dividende salarié Emmanuel Macron
l'avait on a fait une promesse de
campagne on s'en souvient le
gouvernement là dans ces cartons donc ça
veut dire que tout entreprises je résume
un petit peu qui versera qui verserait
des dividendes devra aussi en même temps
verser ce dividende salarié tout ça
inscrit dans la loi c'est un peu résumé
mais c'est ça l'idée c'est un peu ça
mais on va partir d'un dispositif qui
est déjà existant qui est la
participation autrement créé un nouveau
dispositif c'est ce qui est important
c'est de dire que sous la bannière
dividende et je vais y revenir pourquoi
j'ai appelé ça le dividende salarié on
part d'un dispositif existant qui date
des années 67 des ordonnances de 67
voulues par le général de Gaulle qui est
de faire en sorte qu'il y a un meilleur
partage de la valeur et donc il faut
c'était déjà contrasté je pense que plus
de 50 ans après il faut revoir ce
dispositif parce que le partage de la
valeur est un acte de réconciliation que
nous devons avoir avec les salariés les
actionnaires je pense qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est très simple c'est que
regarder on est probablement le seul
pays au monde en tout cas en Europe où
chaque fois qu'on verse des dividendes
et qu'on les dividende sont importants
on crie oh là là c'est disproportionné
c'est trop important voire même c'est
une spoliation qui est fait sur le dos
de l'entreprise du salarié il n'y a pas
un pays où globalement ça se passe mal
quand on verse des dividendes qui est
quand même signe de vitalité de notre
économie ce dividende salarié plutôt que
de parler en tout cas de dividendes
salariés pourquoi est-ce que on pourrait
pas juste dire bah la participation et
ben on double son montant on a une
formule du calcul plus intéressante plus
avantageuse pour pour le salarié et en
étant à tous les salariés notamment aux
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés pour
aujourd'hui c'est facultatif moi ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est arrêtons-nous
une minute sur le dividende salarié et
j'invite tous les spectateurs à regarder
dans le code du travail alors qui est un
peu épais le chapitre 3 du Code du
travail et on découvre dans le chapitre
3 du Code du travail que les instruments
d'intéressement et de participation se
nomme dividende travail et quand j'ai
essayé de théoriser ce dividende salarié
ce meilleur partage de la valeur partir
au moment où il y avait la prime dites
Macron qui est devenu prime partage de
la valeur un troisième dispositif qui
s'est on va dire avancer et ben je me
suis dit finalement il faut renommer ça
du dividende et le dividende salarié
c'est chaque entreprise qui verse les
dividendes doit verser de la
participation c'est ça le thème mais
aujourd'hui toute boîte qui fait des
bénéfices de plus 50 salariés doit
verser une participation alors oui mais
vous avez des entreprises qui versent
pas de participation parce qu'elles sont
organisées de telle façon
contenu de la formule de participation
qui ne verse pas de participation et
donc il faut regarder un contournement
il y a une forme de contournement
d'optimisation et puis vous l'avez dit
justement vous avez 150000 entreprises
on va dire de PME vous avez des moyennes
PME des grosses PME fait un peu près 10
millions de salariés et sur ces 10
millions de salariés vous avez que 2
millions 3 qui sont couverts par un
dispositif d'intérêt de participation
donc 50% des salariés du privé
exactement
ce qui revient à peu près à ça ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut probablement rendre
ce dispositif accessible à l'ensemble
des entreprises à l'exception des moins
de 11 où là la prime partage de la
valeur peut fonctionner parce que il
faut la simplicité mais oui dans les PME
dans les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire il faut que l'on puisse
mettre en place de la participation ce
dividende salarié il pourrait
représenter combien de mois de salaire
je sais pas si on peut leur poser la
question comme ça alors aujourd'hui si
on regarde les masses
intéressement plus participation ça
représente à peu près 20 milliards
on va dire
redistribuer aux salariés si on regarde
la participation c'est globalement 11
milliards
et par montant unitaire par salarié mais
ce qui veut pas forcément dire
grand-chose parce que là on fait une
division c'est un montant qui va à peu
près de 2000 à 3000 euros selon la
taille de l'entreprise alors évidemment
il y a des petites entreprises qui vont
donner 500 mais ça peut représenter
globalement c'est ça l'idée en
renforçant le mécanisme de la
participation un mois à 13e ou 14e mois
parce que ce que je propose dans le
dividende salarié c'est plusieurs choses
c'est un c'est de doubler le montant la
participation pour les grandes
entreprises le rendre on va dire
systématique dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 et puis de mettre en place
une formule de participation pour les
PME qui soit plus audible et plus
accessible la participation c'est pas
déjà une forme de dividende du travail
puisque on sait qu'elle est assise sur
le bénéfice de l'entreprise ils avaient
raison c'est au plus près du dividende
donc c'est déjà une cote part du
dividende donc voilà mais je leur ai
explique dans la théorie du dividende
salarié d'ailleurs voilà c'est contrasté
le patronat aura sa vision les syndicats
par la vision en parler donc je le
réhabilite d'une certaine façon mais oui
vous avez raison la formule de
participation alors si je la donne là je
pense que tout le monde va se coucher
à juste titre il faut la simplifier mais
elle est déjà une quote part du
dividende
cet ancien numéro 2 du Medef la Thibault
langsad le patronat n'est pas fan et
vous le savez de votre dividende salarié
pour le patronat ça augmente le coût du
travail et sa nuit à la compétitivité
ce dividende salarié j'ai envie de dire
oui et non ça augmente
ce sont des dispositifs qui sont on va
dire souvent dénuées de fiscalité de
quoi c'est ce qu'on appelle le
forcercial pour les grandes entreprises
il est inexistant pour les entreprises
de moins de 250 salariés sur
l'intéressement et inexistant sur la
participation pour les moins de 50
salariés donc ce sont des dispositifs
qui peuvent être gagnants gagnants mais
le vrai sujet c'est la réconciliation un
meilleur partage de la valeur et ça
c'est une aspiration que nous voulons
tous et donc un problème de partage de
la valeur en France oui un sujet sur le
partage de la valeur les primes la
participation l'intéressement l'épargne
salariale mais au global il y a un
problème de partage je pense que on a
besoin davantage de sens et de être
mieux associés à la performance de
Londres ça veut dire qu'on prend à qui
on prend l'investissement on prend aux
dividendes aux actionnaires pas qu'il
faut il faille le raisonner comme ça je
pense que la nécessité c'est d'avoir des
investissements qui permettent le gâteau
pas infini non mais il faut aussi avoir
des instruments qui permettent d'avoir
une répartition légèrement plus
équitable quand l'entreprise sur
performes c'est le sujet que nous avons
aujourd'hui je dis pas que quand une
entreprise est en difficulté elle peut
pas verser le dividendes elle va pas
d'intéressement de participation mais
quand vous avez des résultats
exceptionnels c'est quand même le cas de
nos entreprises et une fois de plus
c'est à la gloire de notre industrie
c'est à la gloire de notre économie tant
mieux ça nous permet d'avoir un chômage
en diminution de verser une contribution
on va dire fiscale plus importante en
2022 qui permettra à l'état de mieux
équilibrer son budget donc on a une
contribution mais quand on a des
résultats importants d'avoir un meilleur
partage de la valeur 53 après revoir les
dispositifs intéressants de
participation je pense que ça vaut le
coup allez merci beaucoup Thibault lança
donc président de lumineux c'est
président de l'URSSAF merci merci alors
quelles sont les autres solutions pour
mieux partager la valeur au sein de
l'entreprise on en parle tout de suite
avec le patron de la CFDT
[Musique]
comment mieux associer les salariés au
succès de leur entreprise on en parle
avec vous Laurent Berger bonjour bonjour
secrétaire général de la CFDT ce partage
de la valeur c'est pas un sujet qui est
nouveau ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
des décennies diront certains et je me
rappelle Nicolas Sarkozy en son temps
qui parlait de la règle des trois tirs à
propos de la répartition des bénéfices
entières pour les actionnaires un tiers
pour les investissements et un tiers
pour les salariés ça n'a jamais vu le
jour vous le regrettez pas à l'époque à
la tête de la CFDT c'est une bonne
répartition vous pourriez signer ça
aujourd'hui bah le principe d'un tiers
un tiers 1/3 peut paraître un peu ne pas
tenir compte de la diversité des
entreprises mais en tout cas ce principe
que dans le partage de la valeur créée
il y en ait un tiers pour les
actionnaires un tiers pour
l'investissement et un tiers qui aille
au travailleur pour le pour parce qu'ils
ont participé à la création de valeur
effectivement le principe est
intéressant après est-ce qu'il faut le
faire avec autant de de de précision je
suis pas sûr on peut aussi estimer que
la négociation entreprise permettrait de
d'affiner selon la situation de chaque
entreprise ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui
c'est que on le voit dans le partage de
la valeur ajoutée depuis des années
la part des salaires à peu près stable
oui mais il y a eu un phénomène
d'optimisation fiscale grandissant qui
fait que il y a une part grandissante de
la richesse créée dans certains nombre
de grandes entreprises qui échappent
d'une part à la richesse nationale d'une
certaine manière par la fiscalité mais
qui échappe à la redistribution de la
valeur donc on a une distorsion qui sont
qui s'est opérée de salaire puisque la
part des salaires dans la valeur ajoutée
depuis la fin des années 80 chiffres
vous l'avez dit que tout ça est stable
il y a un sujet salaire y compris la
négociation qu'on est en train de mener
nous on dit on peut pas mettre de côté
le sujet salaire mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a au-delà de ça le sujet participation
intéressement dispositif de de
répartition de la valeur créée envers
les salariés qui est aujourd'hui très
insuffisante après il y a la question
sur la question du salaire
évidemment il y a l'inflation et donc
de l'inflation ce sujet la plus partage
de la valeur comme on augmente pas les
salaires revient sur la table mais déjà
sur la question des augmentations de
salaire le compte n'y est pas
aujourd'hui on a cours on a 6%
d'inflation sur 2022 3,7% de salaire
nous a dit le ministère du Travail ça
rattrapera pas l'inflation d'autres
mécanismes à côté le compte n'est pas ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que d'abord les
salaires doivent suivre les mécanismes
d'inflation c'est-à-dire que il doit
avoir des négociations salariales dans
les entreprises dans les branches
professionnelles qui permettent de
compenser l'inflation c'est-à-dire que
c'est donc vous souhaitez on veut pas
l'indexer nous on veut des négociations
vous savez aujourd'hui il y a à chaque
revalorisation du SMIC on est à peu près
à 130 branches qui sont en dessous qui
démarrent avec des minimas en dessous du
SMIC là il faut des mécanismes beaucoup
plus dynamiques dans les branches en
termes de négociation et donc il faut
des incitations en direction des
branches professionnelles du côté
patronal pour négocier donc il y a un
sujet salaire qui est posé à travers ses
branches et à travers les négociations
annuelles obligatoires
aujourd'hui si on fait le bilan sur 2022
il y a des endroits où ça s'est passé
avec des négociations salariales qui ont
été à la hauteur des endroits où on a
des stations salariales qui ne
compensent pas l'inflation et il y a eu
parfois des augmentations à travers la
prime de la prime Paypal ou donc qui
compensaient plus ou moins il y a des
endroits où ça ne compense pas du tout
il y a des secteurs professionnels où il
y a une perte de pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait énorme là je crois
qu'il faut vraiment inciter à une
revalorisation des des grilles
salariales dans les branches
professionnelles vous savez quand vous
avez trois ou quatre échelons qui sont
en dessous le SMIC avant même de avant
même de discuter dans les entreprises du
salaire ça veut dire que vous restez au
SMIC pendant des mois et des mois des
années des années sans compenser de
reconnaître d'abord votre compétence
votre classification et sans compenser
les pertes de pouvoir d'achat donc il y
a vraiment une logique de politique
salariale qu'il faut distinguer de de
la discussion qu'on a aujourd'hui sur le
partage de la valeur ajoutée mais il
faut le distinguer mais la question
salariale doit être intégrée quand même
la discussion qu'on a avec le patrona
wake c'est un peu compliqué comme moi le
travail le salaire c'est ce que vous
vous recevez en fonction de la tâche que
vous effectuez c'est ce qu'on vous paye
pour faire ce travail le partage de la
valeur c'est ce qui vous revient quand
vous êtes un salarié parce que vous avez
créé de la valeur ça passe donc pas
seulement par le salaire les hausses de
salaire mais il y a aussi les prix
la participation m'intéressement le
numéro 2 du Medef me disait Patrick
Martin quand on met tout ça bout à bout
ça compense l'inflation tous ces
mécanismes c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai le le en moyenne faudrait
regarder ça se discute mais c'est pas
les moyens qui comptent vous voyez bien
que les salariés de ce pays ils en ont
un peu assez qu'on les considère en
moyenne c'est-à-dire puisque il y a eu
des augmentations qui dans certains
secteurs c'est vrai parce qu'il y a de
la valeur créée ou parce que il y a
beaucoup de participation
d'intéressement
masque finalement la réalité de salariés
plus modeste ça marche pas vous savez
les dispositifs de participation
intéressante ça existe pour à peu près
en moyenne 55 % des des salariés mais
83% des salariés des grandes entreprises
en bénéficient et 17% les autres des
salariés de moins de 10 donc vous voyez
c'est pour arrêter de fonctionner en
moyenne aujourd'hui dans tout un tas
d'entreprises il y a pas de mécanisme
distribution de la valeur de la valeur
créée c'est pour ça que nous dans la
négociation réclame la participation des
dispositifs de participation ou
d'intéressement obligatoire de
l'entreprise et un calcul simplifié
aujourd'hui cette obligatoire la
participation au-delà de 50 salariés
vous plaidez-vous pour abaisser ce seuil
pour élargir la participation
de participation pour toutes les
entreprises obligatoires et que ce soit
avec un mécanisme de calcul qui soit
très simple que dit patronat le patronat
est opposé à ça la négociation est
aujourd'hui dans une forme d'impasse en
tout cas dans une grosse difficulté le
patronat aujourd'hui les seules
propositions qu'il fait c'est
non obligations de mécanisme de
participation et
allègement fiscaux
qui existent déjà renforcement le
renforcement du forfait social
renforcement des allègements fiscaux
pour distribuer de de
enfin le fruit de la valeur créée aux
salariés franchement c'est pas sérieux
donc on est dans une négociation qui est
aujourd'hui est en panne du certaine
manière on a jusqu'au 31 janvier on a
une dernière séance le 31 janvier moi je
le dis au patronat de toute façon c'est
très sérieux je leur dis en direct aussi
si vous ne trouvez pas un point d'accord
si on n'arrive pas à trouver un point
d'accord et vous ne faites pas un effort
de toute façon on plaidera après auprès
du gouvernement pour qu'un dispositif
obligatoire existe mais mais prenez
conscience que c'est beaucoup moins
intelligent que si on était capable de
trouver un point d'accord ce que propose
le gouvernement c'est notamment cette
prime Macron versée en 2021 à 4 millions
de salariés pour un montant moyen de 500
euros montant qui a été rehaussé en 2022
à 710 euros est-ce que c'est bien on se
dit qu'on est loin du plafond de 6000
euros potentiel et puis c'est au bon
vouloir de l'employeur donc c'est
d'abord dire lorsque des salariés 4
millions de salariés et touche 500 euros
de plus à travers une prime dire que
c'est pas bien
pas le faire quand on a un syndicaliste
parce que j'imagine que pour un certain
nombre de salariés ça a été bénéfique
mais un c'est pas obligatoire vous
l'avez dit deux ça sert à rien de fixer
un plafond astronomique pour finalement
ne pas avoir ne pas ne pas y arriver et
3 nous on pense que c'est dispositifs de
prime ça doit être en cas de non de non
de non accords
participation c'est à dire que ça peut
pas être le dispositif pérenne vous
voyez ce que je veux dire il faut un
dispositif qui soit obligatoire là c'est
au bon vouloir donc il y a eu des
périodes spécifiques avec le covid la
période poscovide l'inflation etc on a
bien vu que ça a pu marcher pour 4
millions c'est pas neutre mais ça ne
marchera pas les années les années à
venir si on rend pas ça obligatoire
d'autant que Philippe Martinez le patron
de la CGT dit et c'est vrai une prime
c'est ponctuel alors que le salaire
c'est tous les mois mais en même temps
de manière exceptionnelle une prime ça
peut aider à booster le pouvoir d'achat
oui vous savez c'est toujours faut pas
être déconnecté de la réalité quand vous
versez
et il faut il peut y avoir dispositif de
prime mais nous ce qu'on préconise avant
tout c'est des revalorisations
salariales et des dispositifs de
répartition de la richesse créée
d'entreprise qui soit pérenne donc pour
tous c'est participation pour tous c'est
clair bon d'ailleurs le gouvernement va
mettre en place le dividende salarié en
gros dès qu'une entreprise verse des
dividendes aux actionnaires elle doit
récompenser aussi ses salariés ça vous
plaît c'est saugrenu vous n'êtes pas
contre parce que c'est une façon de
contraindre quelque part les patrons à
redistribuer la valeur peu importe ce
soit le bon terme ou pas ça existe enfin
on peut le faire en élargissant les
dispositifs de participation ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut se dire c'est il se
passe quoi c'est qu'est-ce qu'on entend
par dividende verset vous voyez dans
tout un tas d'entreprises ça sera pas la
dividende notamment les entreprises
assez petites ce sera pas la dividende
versée à des actionnaires dont on sait
pas où en fonction du cours de la bourse
donc il faudra trouver une méthode de de
calcul qui soit autre nous on est plutôt
en fonction de des bénéfices
créés par entreprise qu'il y a une part
qui est mécaniquement automatiquement
reverse ça s'appelle la participation
ouais bien sûr voilà c'est pour ça que
j'ai essayé de l'expliquer différemment
mais ça s'appelle la participation mais
oui c'est ça qu'il faut faire il faut un
dispositif simplifié dans le calcul déjà
on est là il faut l'élargir le rendre
obligatoire aux entreprises de moins de
50 salariés bien sûr aux entreprises de
moins de 50 et
pas avec un système minimum de
participation avec non je crois que avec
le calcul sur une base 100 il y a 100 de
valeur créée il faut qu'on calcule qu'il
y a tant qui reviennent aux salariés
parce qu'ils ont participé à la création
de cette région une formule de calcul
qui est très complexe très complexe pour
la simplifier objectivement faut la
simplifier
pour les salariés oui je vous remercie
de le proposer mais non mais c'est
surtout faut la simplifier parce que
l'idée c'est pas de complexifier ce que
disent ce que disent ce que vivent des
chefs d'entreprise dans les petites
entreprises mais si c'est simple c'est
un pourcentage et que c'est et que c'est
facile à calculer il y a aucune raison
de pas le généraliser et aussi un autre
mécanisme qui plait au gouvernement
c'est la super participation en gros
elle traverse salarié des entreprises
qui réalisent des super dividendes en
gros des dividendes qui sont supérieurs
de 20% à la moyenne des 5 dernières
années pardon c'était pour être précis
là aussi vous êtes ouvert quel que soit
le nom l'appellation en fait
nous on est ouvert à ça et il faut il
faut effectivement que quand il y a des
versements beaucoup de versements de
dividendes ça il y a aussi une part qui
a eu salarié mais on aurait tort dans le
débat actuel de polariser seulement sur
les grandes entreprises dont on connaît
les grands noms et dans on se dirait
c'est celle là celle-là parce que bah on
a tort les stigmatiser en tout cas on a
tort de croire que de faire croire qu'on
aura réglé le problème de partage de la
valeur ajoutée quand on aura traité le
sujet dans ces entreprises là c'est ce
que dit le patron de la CGT en disant
regardez 80 milliards d'euros de
dividendes vers fonctionnaires sur le
CAC 40 mais sur les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires il y a deux il y a deux
actions qu'il faut mener c'est il faut
de l'inversement salarié à proportion
c'est une évidence et puis il faut
regarder aussi ça veut dire de
participation qui soit et les boutiques
d'ailleurs souvent dans les grands
groupes super participation etc oui bien
sûr pour ça c'est pour ça vous savez il
faut pas se masquer derrière quelques
quelques réalités qui existent et sur
lesquelles il faut traiter les choses
pour qu'il y a un meilleur partage de la
valeur ajoutée dans les grandes
entreprises mais en se disant quand on
aura réglé ça on aura réglé le problème
de travailleurs dans tout dans toutes
les entreprises c'est pas vrai le
problème il est d'abord pour les
entreprises de les petites les petites
entreprises des entreprises de taille
intermédiaires les PME etc où il faut
trouver un mécanisme facile à mettre en
œuvre qui permettent la le partage la
valeur ajoutée dans les grandes
entreprises si vous voulez sur les faits
bon vivre pardon pour les salariés dans
les grandes entreprises ils ont la
participation les salariés ils ont
l'intéressement ils ont il y a beaucoup
de choses oui mais bien sûr parce que
parce qu'il y a eu de l'action syndicale
aussi bien sûr parce qu'il y a de la
richesse créée ça veut pas dire que il
faut pas qu'on réfléchisse quand même à
des dividendes qui sont qui sont chaque
année en tout cas depuis deux ans
toujours plus important l'idée pour la
CFDT c'est pas simplement de le partager
la valeur mais sur les le le le
dividendes notamment ce que rapporte le
capital je crois qu'il y aura besoin
aussi de d'aller vers une politique
fiscale qui soit qui soit plus juste et
qu'on a baissé l'impôt sur les sociétés
pour être dans la moyenne européenne je
pense que la France qui revient de loin
oui oui mais il y a la CFDT elle a
jamais été pour le contreistorait des
marches aux entreprises vous savez le
pacte de responsabilité le cice etc ça
peut avoir de du sens mais quand
les super dividendes ou il y a outrance
d'une certaine manière dans le versement
des dividendes parfois avec des
mécanismes d'optimisation fiscale etc il
est pas anormal de se reposer la
question de comment il peut ça peut
contribuer aussi à la richesse nationale
s'il y a trop de dividendes c'est au
détriment des des salariés des salaires
on va pas dans toutes les entreprises ça
peut être dans certaines entreprises ça
peut être au détriment des salariés et
de leur salaire de leur de leur
participation y compris parce qu'elle
n'existe pas mais dans d'autres dans
d'autres cas ça peut être au détriment
de la valeur de la de la richesse
nationale quand on parle de
l'enrichissement des actionnaires on dit
souvent il vient des dividendes mais si
on regarde bien les choses ça vient
plutôt ça vient des dividendes bien sûr
mais surtout de la valorisation des
marchés boursiers et si les bourses sont
beaucoup montés regarde le poids
boursier du CAC40 dans le PIB c'était
50% en 98 on est à 100% aujourd'hui
c'est de la faute entre guillemets
notamment des banques centrales des
politiques de taux d'intérêt très très
faible donc l'enrichissement des
actionnaires est venu pour partie
dividendes surtout de la hausse de la
valeur de leurs actifs liés aux
politiques monétaires extrêmement
simulant stimulante pendant des années
et des années donc on est sorti
d'ailleurs là aujourd'hui mais c'est
pour ça que il faut pas que c'est plus
complexe que vous savez il y a deux
choses il faut pas deux risques qu'il
faut vers lequel il faut pas aller le
premier qui serait de dire il y a rien à
bouger là-dessus et la répartition de la
valeur créée est non elle est pas juste
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité s'engager dans cette dans cette
négociation et qu'on espère que si elle
n'aboutit pas
oui mais le gouvernement pendant sa
spontanéité puis à l'autre risque
d'avoir lequel il faut pas tomber qui
serait de trouver anormal que quelqu'un
qui investit n'est pas injuste retour de
son investissement et sa prise de risque
mais il y a une distorsion aujourd'hui
une profonde distension qui s'est créée
notamment dans certains secteurs
professionnels mais surtout dans
certaines entreprises et donc le
rétablissement de la répartition entre
le capital et le travail il est
absolument nécessaire pour que ce soit
plus juste et pourquoi ne pas plaider à
Laurent Berger pour une un développement
une massification de l'actionna salarié
comme ça on aligne un peu les intérêts
entre les actionnaires et les salariés
vous savez quand vous êtes salarié vous
vous effectuez un travail et vous vous
êtes rémunéré pour mais vous avez pas
intérêt à mettre tous les autres
c'est clair on l'a connu ça on l'a connu
dans certaines entreprises
vous avez votre actionnariat votre
épargne certaines manières qui est en
action dans votre entreprise de
travailler et puis c'est votre salaire
aussi et puis le jour où ça où ça
flanche vous n'avez vous vous n'avez
plus vous n'avez plus de possibilités de
de survivre et puis il y a un autre
élément je tiens à le dire c'est ça
c'est c'est du partage de la valeur il
est aussi la question du partage du
pouvoir et de la responsabilité
d'entreprise c'est-à-dire que la
gouvernance ouais ça va de pair pour
nous ça va de pairs on le dit d'ailleurs
dans la négociation le partage de la
dans la gouvernance la participation des
représentants du travail à des choix
stratégiques à un moment donné les
fondamental on a progressé depuis 2013
avec la partie passion des représentants
des salariés dans les conseils
d'administration on peut aller plus loin
aussi on résume ce qu'on s'est dit il y
a pas de consensus au sein des
partenaires sociaux pour l'instant non
la dégustation n'est pas terminée mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de on n'est pas
sur la bonne voie pour un accord parce
que donc ça risque de finir avec le
dividende salarié
oui mais là encore
le moment venu je dirais au gouvernement
il faudra faire quelque chose
d'intelligent qui soit qui soit quand
même dans praticable pour que le but
finalement c'est que la richesse soit
mieux répartie d'entreprise notamment
dans les pays que ce soit pas juste
cosmétiques notamment dans les petits
pays et les moyens d'entreprise je vous
remercie pour cette entretien à vous
secrétaire général de la CVT merci
beaucoup voilà c'est la fin de pourvu
que ça dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondables sur Public Sénat et
mission à voir ou revoir sur Public
Sénat qui a du replay bien sûr sur
public senna.fr rendez-vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure vous a été présenté
par écho DDS éco-organismes qui agit
pour une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]